when I was growing up Nintendo was the
thing the original NES console Super
Mario Legend of Zelda Metroid Mike
Tyson's punch-out Battletoads eluate
Battletoads then we got into Sega and
all things Sonic then Super Nintendo
came out and I played a lot of Donkey
Kong Country Aladdin and turtles of time
Nintendo 64 was a revelation mario 64
mario kart the lesser-known but still
great diddy kong racing and of course
the masterpiece of masterpieces ocarina
of time for many kids my generation and
after videogames were just a part of
growing up after school i'd go to one of
my friends houses and we play 64 or a
sega saturn for a few hours go outside
run around play some more go home we
played video games because it was
something to do like playing horse in
the driveway or wall ball it was just
another form of competition the pure
competition of games which is just a way
of filling free time with purpose the
last console i ever owned was
playstation 2 and i fell off gaming when
gaming got much more complicated than
the side-scrolling that I grew up with
if at that time you would have asked me
can video games be art I would have said
I'm 13 what do I know my opinion on it
now is that those games were games the
objectives were clear the rules
relatively simple like soccer or
basketball or any other sport the
primary purpose of the experience was to
win in the period since games have
become vastly more complicated and the
question of whether or not that form is
an art a fine art has become the topic
of serious philosophical debate legally
of course that decision was decided on
much more specific terms it started in
the early 80s when a series of American
Court decisions found that video games
could not be covered under arts free
speech protections because they were no
more expressive than pinball or chess
those precedents determine much of what
followed in 2002 federal judge Stephen
Limbaugh ruled against the protection of
games saying that like bingo the court
fails to see how video games express
ideas impressions feelings or
information unrelated to the game itself
not until 2011 did the matter
get the definitive decision that it
deserved when the Supreme Court finally
extended arts protections to video games
in Brown versus the entertainment
Merchants Association in a 7 to 2 ruling
of course the legal definition of video
game stands quite apart from their
philosophical definition but in the
timespan of all those legal decisions
the scope of video games has expanded to
include things like Myst Grand Theft
Auto The Sims RPGs with narratives more
compelling than most science fiction in
Hollywood or contemporary literature
games today have real and fully realized
economies like the one which was shaken
to its core in EVE Online in this mega
space battle from earlier this year
destroyed in-game spaceships to the tune
of 300 thousand real dollars and
visually I don't know if you can get
more digitally sophisticated than the
cinematics for games like Batman Arkham
Asylum or elder scrolls I don't know if
you can find an experienced more elegant
than the gameplay for Super Mario Galaxy
or feds do all of these things complex
as they are add up to art well at the
core of this is the question of whether
something that must be categorized as a
game can also be categorized as a work
of art to be sure all kinds of artistic
expression involve some interaction with
the source material but is the physical
interaction in gaming of some kind of
qualitatively disqualifying kind I've
always been a stickler for distinctions
for philosophical labels but it's
questions like this that make me think
about why people are very precious about
art and they try to include all the
things they love under its masthead like
advertising or cooking but to me the
desperate attempt to have games included
in the art speaks less to the
significance of the category of art then
the curious lack of significance we
attach in comparison to the category of
games the extraordinary injection of
subtlety and beauty into the universe of
video games seems to me a herald of what
gaming can and will be to us in the
in the 2012 game called journey you play
as a robed figure in the desert moving
slowly gracefully wordlessly toward a
shining mountain in the distance the
goal is singular but gradually informed
by traces of a faded civilization that
you discover along the way the gameplay
the music the symbolism of the culture
that was lost puts you in an emotional
space unique to all other forms of media
reaching the mountain is like an
apotheosis and like the apotheosis of
art it is the kind that life itself is
incapable of sustaining contained in
this game is a meditation both on the
unspoiled image of what we want and it's
profound unsatisfactory reflection what
we are [ __ ] yet for videogames
thanks for watching and allowing a sort
of non-gamer to take part in this really
fascinating discussion
I still do play Mario Kart on a regular
basis so that should get me something if
you like this video please share it on
reddit um that's just been the best way
to get these videos out there and follow
me on Twitter and Tumblr and ask me
anything you want in the comments and I
will reply to you I'll see you next
Friday